cuál de los siguientes pares ordenados
es una solución a la siguiente ecuación
menos 3x menos o igual a 6 tenemos estas
opciones y tenemos que recordar que
cuando hay un paro ordenado el primer
número es la coordenada mx y el segundo
número es la coordenada en g para la
primera opción lo que nos dicen es que
si x es menos 4
y ya es 4 esto cumplirá con esta
ecuación pues podemos sustituirlos para
saber la respuesta tenemos menos 3 y
cada que encontremos una equis la vamos
a reemplazar con un menos cuatro
y en donde nos encontremos una y vamos a
reemplazarla con un 4 menos 3 x menos 4
menos cuatro igual a 6
esto nos da 12 menos 4
lo que nos da un 86 esto no se cumple
así que la primera opción no funciona
hagamos lo mismo con la segunda opción
veamos qué pasa cuando x es menos 3 y
estrés positivo al sustituirlo tenemos
menos 3 por equis y ahora nuestra equis
vale menos 3
a menos que ahora vale 3 y todo esto
debe ser igual a 6 bueno menos 3 x menos
3 nos da 99 menos 3 es en efecto igual a
66 es igual a 6 así que esto es correcto
esta segunda opción es la buena es un
palo ordenado que es solución a esta
ecuación